joe biden has promised a new day for
america
but what does biden have in mind for
asia the u.s has a powerful reach there
over security
trade and climate change but also a
rival for economic and military
dominance
a confident china which has managed so
far to beat back its coronavirus
epidemic
and now looks to outmaneuver the u.s as
a global superpower
meanwhile protest movements in thailand
and hong kong
look to the u.s as a champion of
democracy for the region
in nuclear-armed north korea the u.s
faces an existential threat
president trump tried cozying up to kim
jong-un but his personal touch did
nothing to rid the dictatorship
of its long-range nuclear missiles
the trump administration had more
success with the quad relationship
an alliance of democracies japan india
the us and australia
as a counterweight to china's
expansionist ambitions
like in the south china sea ties that
biden
may seek to bolster but as a politician
who prides himself
on collaboration and consensus in his
own style
joining us is matthew brooker he's
managing editor of bloomberg opinion
asia matthew let's start with where
you're at in hong kong
people have strong feelings there about
trump versus biden
and who would support the pro-democrats
more what's your assessment now we know
it's going to be biden
i i think you're quite right melissa
there is a very strong
support for trump in in the um
in the pro-democracy camp and certainly
among the
protesters um
they really see uh you know i i think
it's a case of
my enemies enemy is my friend they may
not be so
tuned in to the way that uh trump
behaves on his home turf they just see
somebody who's been very strong in
opposing
the chinese communist party and what
they've been doing in the city here
i i see that you're working from home
and the kids are in the background
something that a lot of people have to
deal with these days not a problem at
all
um but moving on to now moving on to
china
how will biden's engagement with china
be different
i i think you know the very clear
difference that you're going to see is
we're just going to have a much more
predictable
character in the white house uh trump
obviously took a very confrontational
and very pugilistic
attitude to china and approach uh and
that was
you know clearly uh appreciated by some
people in this region
i think the the downside of that has
been that um
it's very scatter shop scatter shot
approach and it's
uh alienated um many of the us's uh
allies around the world i think with
biden in place what you're going to see
is a
is a return to a much more multilateral
approach that
seeks to bring in allies and um build a
kind of united front now let's talk
about
india modi and trump had a very good
relationship
do you think that'll be the case with
biden or will we be seeing the americans
put
a little bit more pressure on india when
it comes to human rights violations for
example
yes that's it india is an interesting
one obviously you had this uh
very quite bizarre loving between trump
and modi
nothing namaste trump return in india
um so in that respect there's uh
i i think you know modi certainly may be
not particularly happy to see trump
defeated
on the other hand of course biden's vice
president has
indian heritage and i think there's a
lot of excitement a lot of pride in
india about that
and that you know maybe sets the stage
for there to be
a warmer relationship in some ways
but clearly biden has been more
vociferous on human rights issues and
that is a
is an area of potential tension in the
in the u.s india relationship
now on to japan how will that close
relationship change or will it
i don't think you're going to see very
fundamental change in the japan
relationship i mean obviously
japan is the us's closest ally
in asia probably the closest ally and i
think they'd be
prepared to work with whoever is in the
white house
um you know i hear that on the on the
conservative side of the spectrum
in japan they may not be so happy to see
trump go
because uh from their perspective the
obama years
were a bit too soft on china um
they didn't really see china as being
the looming threat that
i think is perceived to be
across the political spectrum um
in the us now um but on
you know i really the same applies as as
for india and china
biden is going to be much more
predictable
and um you know i don't think that
whoever's in the white house
that the you know china really looms
over everything whichever
bilateral relationship you're talking
about in asia i think that's
going to be one thing that's a key
concern to japan and i don't think
that's
really going to change very much under
biden
matthew brooker thank you so much for
your time
you